our guest today is dr martin striber
he's a cardiac surgeon at the leipzig
heart center dr striver welcome to the
program the man in that last report had
a temporary artificial device what about
a permanent or long-term artificial
heart is that on the horizon
well first of all this device
the man had implanted was intended as a
bridge to transplant but since the
numbers of implants
are much higher than the numbers of
transplants many many of these people
have to live with these devices for
years
the other concept you showed is a
so-called total artificial heart that is
a very complex machine replacing the
entire heart and we have to see in the
future if it is working without any
problems for many years to become a
real artificial
heart
how long have doctors been working
towards this goal
many many years so it was practically
put in motion in the 60s right after the
first heart transplantation or the moon
landing a few weeks later there was the
first total artificial heart implant
and since then
the development
went on and we have to break through
about 10 years ago
when this art assist devices with a
simple rotor rotary blood pumps become
available because these machines were
the only ones we have that can help the
patients for many years
you brought some pictures with you to
show us more concretely what we're
speaking about let's take a look at this
you can see on the left hand side
this is the device we had at 14 years
ago 2000 and then in the center of the
current device is much smaller and
rotary blood pumps and on the right hand
side a very small device that may become
available in the near future
so you can see on the left hand side
this device was about 1.5 kilograms and
on the right hand side the device are
just 80 grams so the development goes
into miniaturization of these devices
now you say doctors have been working on
this for a very long time about half a
century in fact why is it taking so long
what are the challenges that doctors
face the challenges is more on the
engineering side that we need a pump
that is mechanically stable and not
wearing out
and working for many years without
mechanical problems and i think this is
the breakthrough that was achieved 10
years ago
tell us a little bit about
miniaturization how is that
going to shape the future
you so saw already that the implant
technique will become much less invasive
and
for the near future there would also be
even less invasive techniques of
implanting this very small devices into
the heart to help the heart work so it's
a heart assist device and not a heart
replacement therapy
now when i was doing some research
before the show i read that if you have
an artificial heart you don't have a
pulse is that true
what is true with the rotary blood pumps
because they pump the blood uh in the
constant way
and people only have a pulse when the
native heart is helping
and for example if the people sit at
rest they will not have a pulse if they
start walking and the heart contributes
then the pulse will come back
it's a fascinating topic dr stuber thank
you so much for joining us here on
tomorrow today all right thank you